bonjour nous sommes jeudi 12 mars merci
de nous rejoindre on fit l'écho
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les titres de cette édition
cette semaine à l'occasion du marché
international des professionnels de
l'immobilier d'entreprise saint quentin
en yvelines est en pleine opération
séduction à cannes l'occasion de faire
le bilan de transactions 2014
al'approche direction départementale la
fédération du bâtiment des yvelines un
terrain elle a convié les candidats pour
leur expliquer la situation économique
des artisans du bâtiment
lorsqu'une entreprise est victime d'un
sinistre comment fait-elle pour
recommencer son activité quelles sont
les démarches c'est ce que nous verrons
avec un restaurant des clayes-sous-bois
fermé à la suite d'un incendie en
novembre dernier il vient de réouvrir
ses portes et vous allez le voir les
démarches sont nombreuses et dans notre
entretien cette semaine nous recevons
jérôme vincent geloso bonsoir vous êtes
consultant grands comptes et spécialiste
de l'immobilier d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines vous répondrait à
nos questions sur l'immobilier
d'entreprise afin quentin en yvelines
bilan et perspectives de cette année
mais avant cela passe en revue
l'actualité économique de la semaine
je vous disais en titre le bâtiment les
travaux publics sont un enjeu de taille
pour l'économie évinoise à l'occasion
des élections départementales la
fédération française du bâtiment des
yvelines invite s'invite dans le débat
de la campagne mercredi dernier elle a
convié plusieurs candidats pour leur
expliquer la situation économique des
artisans du bâtiment nous étions sur
place regardez
lutter contre les offres basse à
valoriser l'apprentissage maintenir le
soutien financier voici trois des dix
propositions que la fédération française
du bâtiment veut mettre en avant avec
l'inquiétude une baisse de budget lié
notamment à celle des dotations des
communes entraînant donc la diminution
des marchés
la part des investissements en travaux
de bâtiment a été de l'ordre de 20 %
dans le budget précédent je saurais pas
vous donner le chiffre en grandeur donc
c'est tout de même quelque chose
d'important et encore une fois vu nombre
d'entreprises yvelinois ce travail au
conseil général pour l'année 2014 le
budget s'élevait à 1,2 milliard d'euros
dans les yvelines le bâtiment représente
6800 entreprises dont 3000 sont des
artisans moi je travaille beaucoup sur
les églises et bâtiments anciens pour
les municipalités donc et maintenant
nous sommes obligés de trouver des
marchés alors la crise assad de bien
c'est que le particulier se recentre et
un peu plus sur son immobilier ce qui
lui permet de faire des travaux de
rénovation quand il le peut selon la
fédération près de cent mille emplois
ont été perdus depuis 2008 les candidats
conviés à cette réunion les ont écoutés
et apporter des paroles de soutien mais
pas vraiment de solution la difficile en
effet de faire des propositions en la
matière quand on sait que la principale
compétence du conseil général ce n'est
pas la construction mais le social et
que les investissements en travaux des
collectivités sont soumis au code des
marchés publics et ne peuvent donc pas
favorisé des entreprises d'un secteur
géographique
la fédération du bâtiment ce sont 1200
adhérents
chaque année le nombre d'entrepreneurs
évinois augmente pour les accompagner
différentes initiatives existent la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines organise notamment
des rencontres pour accompagner les
projets du territoire et des nouveaux
entrepreneurs mardi dernier avait lieu
la soirée bienvenue divine elle est
organisée deux fois par an on existe
depuis 2013 écoutez ces précisions
recueillies au micro de william l
l'objectif était de permettre aux
porteurs de projets nouveaux chefs
d'entreprise qui s'implantent est sur le
territoire des yvelines de mieux
connaître leur territoire savoir tous
les atouts que ce territoire a pour eux
et puis leur donner un certain nombre de
conseils et pouvoir rencontrer aussi les
conseillers référents par territoire
l'activité de la société très récente
donc j'ai besoin d'être accompagnés j'ai
besoin d'un certain nombre de conseils
et la cci est déjà répandu un certain
nombre de mes attentes et je viens
compléter les demandes d'informations
que que je peux obtenir
au niveau des connaissances du marché
local et bien entendu des autres
entrepreneurs ce qui m'intéresse
beaucoup c'est partager avec les autres
entrepreneurs pour voir comment on peut
avancer ensemble et pour essayer de
faire de moins d'erreurs possible voilà
et pour information sachez que la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines organise un nouveau
rendez vous il a lieu vendredi donc
demain de 8h30 à 10h donc c'est un
rendez vous qui aura lieu un vendredi
par mois s'appelle express & co au
programme des thèmes clés comme les rh
le développement commercial et le
numérique le thème de demain sera le
financement des entreprises pour plus
d'informations rendez vous sur le site
internet de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles yvelines et
enfin la chambre des notaires de paris
vient de dévoiler les prix de
l'immobilier au dernier trimestre 2014
cette étude fait apparaître une légère
baisse des prix dont le département des
yvelines avec une diminution de 1,8 pour
cent pour les maisons et une baisse de
2,3 pour cent pour les appartements dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines les prix sont aussi globalement
en baisse même s'il ya une certaine
disparité par exemple à elancourt le
prix du mètre carré et 2990 euros il a
perdu 30% de sa valeur en un an les
villes de guyancourt et de versailles
enregistrent également des baisses de
l'ordre de 6,8 pour cent et 4,6 pour
cent seul montigny le bretonneux se
maintient les prix de l'immobilier sont
à la hausse dans cette ville notamment
en ce qui concerne les ventes
d'appartements avec plus vite oui pour
cent sur la dernière année
en ce moment vous savez je vous disais
en titre a lieu le mipim à cannes alors
le mini c'est le marché international
des professionnels de l'immobilier
d'entreprise c'est un rendez vous
incontournable auquel participent
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le territoire en effet de
nombreux projets en cours et tire un
bilan plutôt positif de ces transactions
en 2014 regardez ce reportage avec les
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
118 c'est le nombre de transactions
enregistrées à saint quentin en yvelines
pour 2014 un bilan positif pour le
marché de l'immobilier d'entreprise en
totalité c'est plus de 123 me mètres
carrés de surface qui ont été placés sur
l'agglomération parmi elles deux grosses
entreprises donc de safran qui est
arrivé baxter les salariés vont arriver
cette année mais c'est ces débats qui
ont été signés il ya presque deux ans et
demi c'est à dire entre le moment où une
entreprise décide de venir sur un
territoire dans un bâtiment neuf ou le
bâtiment a fait délivrer les salariés
arrivent il peut se passer deux ans
voir un tout petit peu plus donc c'est
un travail dans la durée depuis
plusieurs années l'immobilier
d'entreprise ne connaît pas de véritable
reprise économique
en ile-de-france il reste plus de 4
millions de mètres carrés de bureaux
disponibles
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise s'en
sort bien avec un taux de vacance de 7%
en 2014 contre 13% en 2010 de nouveaux
projets peuvent potentiellement sortir
de terre est à peu près cent dix mille
mètres carrés d'immobilier d'entreprises
prêtes à construire ce qui va falloir
s'est trouvé des entreprises qui signent
des baux puisque pour que le chantier
puisse démarrer faut que l'investisseur
et déjà signé un bail donc tout l'enjeu
c'est de porter une dynamique économique
le marché international professionnel de
l'immobilier d'entreprise représente un
enjeu important pour assurer la
visibilité de cette dynamique économique
les projets du parc de l'envol de
l'entrée du quartier de villas roi et de
keirin seront à l'honneur cette semaine
et nous conte sinon sur le haut
excusez-moi la nôtre le
l'immobilier d'entreprise pardon c'est
sujet dans notre entretien de la semaine
cette semaine vous l'avez vu c'est une
semaine importante pour l'immobilier
d'entreprise notamment avec le mipim un
événement auquel participent
l'agglomération de saint quentin pour en
parler avec nous en plateau je le
rappelle jérôme vincent genot qui est
consultant grands comptes et
professionnels de l'immobilier
d'entreprise alors tout d'abord j'ai
envie de vous demander un petit point
est ce que vous vous rappelez les enjeux
du mipim qu'est-ce que ça consistait ce
que c'est important d'y être alors c'est
à la fois important mais c'est quand
même très tournée vers l'international
si vous voulez en fait le mipim a été
concurrencé par le simi qui est élu en
décembre porte maillot donc évident
c'est plus facile d'aller au cimic
d'aller à cannes même si c'est très
agréable d'y aller mais c'est qu'un très
internationale c'est plutôt réaliste
pour les investisseurs si vous voulez
internationaux etc - pour les
utilisateurs maintenant ça reste quand
même une référence évidemment alors quel
intérêt pour la communauté de la mare à
sion 50 ans de six rondes à ce qu'il ya
des projets fin des investisseurs
intentions qui peuvent du coup sévère
c'est oui et puis il ya quand même eu
aussi oui des comptes d'utilisateurs
comme mercedès
effectivement donc il faut il faut qu'il
soit il faut se montrer bon même si ça
un petit peu moins d'importance qu'avant
parce qu'avant il n'y avait que le mipim
donc tout le mondial est là maintenant
il un petit peu moins donc c'est il faut
il faut y être et la communauté
d'agglomération a raison d'y aller
évidemment évident mais moi j'aimerais
bien aussi parce que c'est toujours très
agréable on fait plein de rencontres
très intéressant mais
voilà maintenant on parle un petit peu
plus du du cygne mais
comme le cynisme c'est un lieu plutôt de
pain pour être visible sans les
communications s'est pas vraiment ici
que ce fonds se signer les gros contrats
gêne non c'est surtout au niveau
d'investissement voilà où avec dédé des
grandes opérations d'aménagement qui
sont annoncés effectivement ou ping mais
bon pour
les immeubles qui sont autour de nous
c'est pas là bas qu'on va dire tiens at
l acier
grandes surfaces non non non ça c'est un
travail de tous les jours j'aimerais
revenir sur le sujet que nous avons vu
du coup vous l'avez vous l'avez regarde
également qu est ce que vous pensez vous
du bilan est ce que ce sont des bons
chiffres vous avez vous même un avis
plus professionnelle par rapport à ces
chiffres alors oui moi le moi je trouve
que ça en c1 quand même un bonne année
si vous voulez mais c'est un petit peu
parce pourquoi pas ce que c'est on a
fait on a réussi face et keops notre
société le groupe nexity à kheops qui a
réussi à vendre à safran à l'eulex au
siège de nortel 44 me mécary sur 17
hectares c'est sûr entre château fort
émaillé le hameau bon bah c'est sûr que
tôt quand on fait une transaction comme
ça bon les chiffres ne veulent pas dire
grand chose parce que quand on est
habitué à additionner des 200 mètres
carrés ou des 2000 mètres carrés tout
d'un coup on a 1 44 milles donc
effectivement c'est tout ça c'est un
petit peu il ya quand même plusieurs mon
opération et ce constat voilà on peut se
réjouir quand même c'est ça de cette
opération de safran qui arrive donc pour
longtemps puisqu'ils sont ils ont acheté
on se réjouit de l'arrivée mercedes
comme l'année dernière de baxter
effectivement du crédit agricole qui se
fait construire vingt mille mécary
supplémentaires en son campus donc tout
ça c'est les grosses opérations qui sont
très intéressantes par contre c'est vrai
que lyon manque quand même de
transaction il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
beaucoup de transactions évidemment si
on ajoute encore une fois on veut pas la
clientèle des 200 m² des 2000 mètres
carrés des 20000 mais carey c'est pas du
tout la même donc quelque chose
essentielle et cette clientèle ce sont
ces petites et petites pme
oui oui c'est ça bon il ya quand même
beaucoup de demandes pour % de 100
mètres carrés mais mes collègues
n'arrête pas ils ont au 50 demande
d'ailleurs il manque d'offre en petites
surfaces voilà mais par contre c'est
vrai que en dans les 2000 3000 mètres
carrés on a quand même un déficit de nom
d'un énorme et par contre on a des gens
comme comme nissan west europe qui
cherchent à quinze mille mètres carrés
c'est connu c'est sur la place j'espère
qu'ils vont les trouver d'ailleurs donc
ça c'est intéressant et puis on a des
immeubles qui sont plutôt des immeubles
de 7000 macquarie comme le keirin à côté
du vélodrome qui est construit par
sodearif qui ne lanceront pas en blanc
c'est à dire en blanc sans locataires ou
sans l'avoir vendu mais pour les
agglomérations c'est quand même plus
intéressant d'avoir des grandes
entreprises qui s'implantent justement
que des petites tpe ou des plaisirs air
et je suis un petit peu de tout soit un
peu tôt mais c'est vrai quand on peut
dire ben mercedes est venue de
rocquencourt à montigny safran regroupe
ses équipes qui étaient à plaisir qu'ils
étaient à montilliers qui était invité
ici bon ça fait plaisir ça c'est sûr que
c'est céder ses biens pour
l'agglomération justement les
professionnels seront peut-être pas
compte l'importance du secteur de
l'immobilier d'entreprise vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus le mystère à
quel point c'est important pour une
fille justement de récupérer des
entreprises petit trou moros et de les
implanter dans leur territoire oui pour
les taxes foncières bien sûr mais aussi
pour sa france et 2000 personnes qui
vont qui seront ils vont travailler à
terme entre sur château fort et magny
les hameaux donc c'est énorme 2000
personnes c'est 2000 salariés plus toute
leur famille ça fait cinq mille
personnes qui veut qu'ils vont venir
c'est des gens qui viennent s'implanter
mais après il n'y a pas forcément de
recrutement dans l'agglomération d'antan
a reçu oui enfin oui oui si si quand
même par exemple safran il regroupe
comme un lit et recrutent pas mal quand
même si si si si si si leur mercedes bon
c'est vrai qu'ils n'étaient pas très
loin de dirt concours donc énormément
mais c'est quand même important d'avoir
et puis on et puis c'est des référents
si vous voulez on peut dire maintien si
réussie des lumières ce décès venu si
safran est venu si baxter est venu nous
repas ça veut dire qu'ils sont bien si
le crédit agricole continue enfin et lcl
a continué à construire vingt mille
mètres carrés sur son campus ça veut
dire qu'ils sont bien c'est un gage de
qualité pourtant je voudrais revenir sur
le taux de vacance donc une occupation
qui est de 7% est-ce que c'est comment
analyser ce chiffre s'est beaucoup ça
semble peu même temps on voit dans le
terreau est sûre et theater de san
quentin qui a quand même beaucoup de
panneaux à louer comment interpréter ce
chiffre oui oui c'est vrai alors c'est
une moyenne ne veut pas dire grand chose
surtout sur nos territoires encore une
fois mais mais c'est vrai qu'on voit
quand même beaucoup de panneaux il ya
quand même beaucoup d'immeubles vides il
faut bien le reconnaître
park a rien de 4 l'immeuble le mirabaud
qui est-il où il y avait eu rocard qui
est allé au val saint quentin bon
c'est c'est embêtant de savoir voir ces
immeubles là qu'ils font quand même 6000
7000 m² et ça c'est ennuis puis bon je
pavot tout ce vous les énumérer mais
c'est vrai oui quand on envoie et à côté
de ça par contre je sais que mes
collègues des petites surfaces ont du
mal à trouver des petites offre alors
envoyé ces mets donc c'est plus des
grandes entreprises qui ont des goûts
rang des grands ensembles qui ne sont
pas occupés et y restent vacants
intermédiaire jadida intermédiaire parce
que vous voyez on a des mets de la scène
à peu près intermédiaire de deux mille
2000 3000 mètres carrés ça veut dire 150
personnes 150 personnes là c'est vrai
qu'on a un petit peu de mal alors
qu'avant ça se passait bien donc c'est
pour ça que vous voyez des beaux
panneaux qu'ils sont c'est vrai que
c'est pas et encore non mais pas partout
parce que sinon
pourtant le voyez dans le sujet série
xiii et qu'il y avait encore des projets
en construction si les restes justement
des locaux qui sont qui sont vides
pourquoi continuer à construire leur en
fait oui voilà alors le seul anglais
c'est que l'obsolescence des bâtiments
se fait très vite maintenant un imoca 20
ans et n'est plus aux normes
internationales et les gens maintenant
veulent du bbcd bâtiment basse
consommation ils veulent que leurs
salariés soient heureux de travailler
donc ils veulent de la clim ils veulent
des faux plancher ils veulent d aider
les normes modernes et internationales
et et l'ennui c'est qu'on est souvent
des immeubles qui sont quasiment à
démolir regardez l'immeuble de l'insee
qui est en train d'être vendu par les
domaines enfin ils ont fait un appel
d'offres qui est en cours fait 7000 m² à
côté de la gare c'est un immeuble qui
est quasiment à démolir et donc du coup
les projets qui se vendent le mieux ce
sont des projets clés en main c'est
plutôt de la location c'est de la
construction de ce qui marche le nouveau
bolide entreprises en ce moment en tout
cas pour le territoire ben c'est
difficile à dire un station de sa vie
non c'est pas c'est pas évident oui les
clés en main marché marche bien la
preuve encore une fois je reviens
toujours sur e sur mercedes les baxter
enfin on écrivait à l'école mais ça
c'est bien
sinon on a quand même des ddd grande des
grands de grandes utilisateurs oui pour
dédé des très beaux des baux contact là
je pense l'immeuble c'est un peu
confidentiel mais on a quelqu'un qui
change 18 mm qu'avait donc pour
regrouper des équipes qui entravaient
gros chèque s'est fait marrer voilà mai
mais il ya quand même des immeubles qui
vieillissent très vite et d'ailleurs là
où il ya mercedes était l'ancien
immeuble de sodexo que on a réussi à
vendre à un promoteur cfc développement
qui est très connu monsieur bernard de
fait ce qu est la première chose qu'il a
faite avec l'accord de la communauté
d'agglomération c'est qu'il a démoli
mais quelques années il a bien fait
parce que du coup il avait un beau
terrain et quand mercedes a voulu
chercher un terrain pour s'installer il
a pour faire inclure main il a fait un
clé en main et vous lequel et le
territoire où l'agglomération qui peut
être plus en concurrence qui propose
plus ou moins les mêmes services que
l'agglomération 50 ans pour des gens qui
cherchent des grandes surfaces on va pas
se limiter à saint quentin en yvelines
on va regarder aussi sur vélizy on va
garder peut-être aussi sur massy
effectivement parce que ma si bas c'est
quand même bien développé un maintenant
et comme la gare tgv il ya deux gares
rer et
maintenant et c'est pas si loin c'est à
l'autre bout de lorien l'opération
d'intérêt national donc ça aussi on peut
en parler aussi c'est quand même très
bien cette cette opération de
l'international dont fait partie saint
quentin en yvelines mais qui s'étend
bien sûr vers l'essonne avec l'europe
essonne versa grand parent etc
du coup quel quel est selon vous le
secteur de l'immobilier fait il reprend
mais ça fait quand même depuis voilà
qu'il 5,6 ont-ils anti patton comment ça
va ce que ça va repartir que savard
marché ou non ce sont des cycles vous
savez il ya deux ans par exemple on
disait que la défense plus personne ne
voulait y aller alors qu'il y avait cinq
tours disponibles puis finalement ça
s'est très bien très bien et très bien
loué en s'évitant quelques mois donc
voyez c'est vraiment c'est d'ici qu'il
faut tenir bon mais c'est vrai que
parfois oui c'est un fait il faut
beaucoup de patience beaucoup de
patience dans ce métier enfin surtout
pour les grandes les grands comptes
c'est vraiment des choses à long terme
moi et du coup qu'elles sont on va dire
les les éléments avec lesquels vous
attirer les entreprises qu'est ce qui
fait que ce 50 en est une que faire la
différence
l'opération séduction comme on la fnac
et bat déjà les références qu'il ya déjà
les gens qui restent 251 new line et les
belles références qu'il y à déjà et puis
aussi par exemple je prends les meufs du
duc et rim si vous voulez qui est à côté
du vélodrome moi je le travaille à gérer
un mandat de la part de ça des riffs la
filiale de bouygues est qui qui qui a
construit de tout le tout le reste
l'aménagement est d'aider les hôtels
les résidences étudiants c'est quelque
chose qui est très agréable à travailler
parce que au moins on peut dire voyez le
vélodrome il a beaucoup de succès il ya
eu les championnats du monde on a
quelque chose à raconter ça c'est
vraiment un peu plus facile il dit pas
que c'est très facile mais c'est un peu
plus facile quand vous avez un immeuble
perdu un peu aux nues au milieu de nulle
part pour vanter ses mérites c'est pas
évident donc voilà eh bien merci jérôme
insurgés d'avoir répondu à notre
question et nos questions il est venu
sur le plateau en chaîne avec le chiffre
de la semaine
147 euros c'est le prix minimum du mètre
carré à 50 en évidence qui concerne
l'immobilier d'entreprise un chiffre qui
a baissé il était de 153 euros il ya
quelques années le prix maximum du mètre
carré dans les mauvais entreprises se
situent entre 160 et 150 euros mais les
transactions se font en moyenne elles
autour d'une centaine d'euros pour
information en 2014 sachez que 22
milliards d'euros ont été investis dont
l'immobilier d'entreprise dont les trois
quarts en ile de france je vous propose
maintenant de passer à l'entreprise la
scène
et cette semaine nous proposons de
découvrir deux entreprises l'une se
lance dans une nouvelle initiative et
l'autre recommence son activité après un
arrêt de plusieurs mois ce sont des
situations qui arrive souvent alors
comment relancer son activité après un
sinistre inondations incendies ce sont
des incidents qui impacte
considérablement la vie économique des
entreprises surtout lorsqu'elles sont de
taille modeste au clae souvent un
restaurant a été victime d'un incendie
en novembre dernier il a ré ouvert cette
semaine regardez ce reportage des images
signées où il ya elle remarche fini pour
le montage
chef
petite question le père du jour
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui si des noix de
jus de porc à la moutarde à l'ancienne
effet
tout est prêt pour le jour j loïc tisba
soigne les derniers détails avant la
réouverture de son restaurant
en novembre dernier il a dû fermer son
établissement après un incendie
d'origine accidentelle son activité
économique qui a incité stoppé net
pendant plus de trois mois alors
aujourd'hui les habitués ont répondu
présent c'était affreux
on espérait qu'il ait pas de blessés qui
aura tout ça c'était vraiment puis on
s'est renseigné de temps en temps de ce
qu'il avait mis un message téléphonique
où ça va nous est donc la semaine
dernière quand j'ai appris que c'était
la réouverture j'étais concentré pour
bien tous les jeudis avec les copines
tous les jeudis on vient et on est venu
exprès aujourd'hui pour les soutenir du
jour au lendemain ce restaurant implanté
depuis dix ans aux clayes-sous-bois dû
fermer ses portes une période compliquée
pour les gérants ils ont dû
immédiatement entreprendre des démarches
pour la réouverture ça fait un peu
compliqué au début il a eu l'assurance
qu'il faut beaucoup de démarches
administratives
savoir à cause d'un incendie si tout est
bien aux normes pour la suite après ça
s'est décanté il a fait un peu de temps
la mise en route une grosse machine puis
après boire des devis pour les travaux
le facture tendance et trois mois
d'arrêt les six employés les deux
apprentis ont perçu leur salaire mais
ils se sont retrouvés au chômage
technique nouveau personnel
ça nous a pas trop toucher quoi c'est
surtout le patron il a eu beaucoup de
démarches à faire pour l'assurance les
papiers récupérés le maximum qu'ils
gouvernent après un sinistre les
démarches sont lourdes en plus des
dommages financiers selon la fédération
française des sociétés d'assurances les
professionnels font face à un million de
sinistres par an pour chaque entreprise
cela peut représenter des milliers
d'euros de frais dit aux pertes
d'exploitation
l'om qui bloque c'est le côté financier
comme mc l'activité on ne rentre plus
rien mais fort toujours le loyer sur le
véhicule de location l'électricité celle
éventuelle de beaucoup de nos frais
fixes comptes vient à baisser très vite
et là on commence à
trois mois de fermeture en période de
fêtes de fin d'année cela représente une
perte de chiffre d'affaires conséquente
dans la restauration c'est ce que nous
confirme arnaud percheron il est
assureur est habitué de ces dossiers les
principales garanties pour lesquelles il
est
important de vérifier dans son contrat
d'assurance parce qu'elles peuvent
remettre en jeu la pérennité du commerce
ou d'entreprises qu'il a souscrit le
contrat ça va être la responsabilité
civile professionnelle
ça peut être pour des dommages causés à
des tiers et pour l'entreprise ou le
commerce lui-même il faut qu'ils soient
assurés pour sa perte d'exploitation
l'assureur a tout intérêt à faire en
sorte que l'indemnisation se se et voulu
vite un que le l'assuré soit indemnisé
le plus rapidement possible puisque lui
l'assureur il va me de voir son asthme
d'assurer des indemnités de
de perte de chiffre d'affaires qu'ils
n'auraient pas pu réaliser pendant la
fermeture évidemment pendant les travaux
le restaurateur a dû investir près de
90000 euros pour les travaux de son
établissement avec en moyenne une
centaine de couverts par jour il espère
amortir cette dépense rapidement
vous connaissiez les drives des
hypermarchés les drives fermiers et bien
maintenant il ya les drives poissonnier
il en existe moins d'une dizaine en
france à voisins le bretonneux une
poissonnerie a décidé de se lancer dans
une aventure afin de profiter du succès
de ce phénomène de consommation un
reportage réalisé avec la rédaction
romain respect pour le montage
des palourdes du poisson des huîtres
tout droit venu de l'île d'oléron
disponible en quelques clics il ne vous
reste plus qu'à aller les chercher c'est
le principe du drive ouverte depuis un
an cette poissonnerie a décidé de
proposer ce nouveau service une
prestation plutôt commune pour les
supermarchés beaucoup moins répandue
chez les petits commerçants pourtant
elle comporte un certain nombre
davantage ça va m'aider parce que
parce que déjà il n'y a pas de pertes on
commande une journée à l'avance donc je
vais à rungis j'achète en selon mes
ventes donc ceux recevant à faire les
petits prix parce que y aura pas de
perth dans le de migros a peu intéressé
les gens quittent mongel dans l'évent de
famille donc les prix ou être ultra
compétitif et
sauf qu'en plus le demi gros ne
nécessite pas de retravailler le poisson
qui évolue tel quel vincent se fournit
tous les soirs au marché de rungis avec
les commandes internet il peut prévoir
ses ventes à l'avance le client lui
c'est ce fil comme monde il a ensuite 48
heures pour venir chercher ses achats
j'ai récupéré mon commune
ça facilite la vie moi qui suis beaucoup
au travail
je commande sur le site et gien et tout
est prêt en un seul bonheur 25 % des
foyers français se sont déjà laissés
séduire par ce service si la logistique
nécessaire à son fonctionnement est
importante pour les supermarchés les
petits commerçants peuvent s'équiper
plus facilement un simple site internet
suffit patrick germain s'est occupé de
celui de vincent cela ne lui a demandé à
apple que quelques jours aujourd'hui les
technologies permettent de mettre à
disposition du petit commerçant
les technologiques qui était employé
jusqu'à présent par les grands comptes
comme carrefour auchan etc et il pourra
de la sorte faire aussi du commerce en
ligne depuis quatre ans le phénomène du
drive ne cesse de prendre de l'ampleur
en france en 2014 ils ont généré un
chiffre d'affaires de plus de 3
milliards d'euros la poissonnerie du
chemin des pêcheurs vient à peine de
mettre en place son service il faudra
attendre environ un an pour estimer
l'impact sur ses ventes
c'est bientôt la fin de notre émission
mais avant cela passons à l'agenda au
programme de notre agenda deux dates
mardi 17 mars la chambre des métiers et
de l'artisanat des yvelines organise le
break déj le rendez vous a lieu de 11h à
14h à versailles les dédié aux jeunes
dirigeants d'entreprise des chefs
d'entreprises artisanales et des
partenaires de l'artisanat seront
également présents au programme réunions
et conférences autour de cette question
comment développer votre chiffre
d'affaires grâce à votre réseau
relationnel il n'y a pas que des pilotes
des hôtesses et les stewards dans les
transports aériens les perspectives sont
nombreuses et diversifiées elles sont
accessibles parfois sans qualification
et jusqu'à bac +5 en passant par des
formations plus spécialisés comme les
ingénieurs du contrôle et de la
navigation aérienne si ces métiers ce
secteur vous intéresse la cité des
métiers de trappes organise un zoom
métier le mercredi 18 mars de 14 heures
à 16 heures il est animé par air emploi
c'est la fin de notre émission je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de file echo où
nous parlerons notamment d'artisanat je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée